last week csgo debuted a new map and new
changes to its battle royale mode that
is danger zone now while the whole thing
is a cut above the abysmal experience I
had on black site it is still in my
opinion on utter waste of time and
resources from valve
[Music]
all right so a little less than a week
ago valve dropped upon us its latest
patch and what was in it redone cash bug
fixes anti cheat initiatives no it was a
new danger zone map is anyone is still
playing danger zone really danger zone
the new map is called Sirocco not
Morocco get it and it is a bit better
than black site which is the first
iteration of the danger zone
battle royale maps and while an
improvement is a positive thing I'm
gonna tell you a little later why that
doesn't even matter and it's still a
waste of time but first if you've never
played CS goes battle royale mode you
didn't miss much the danger zone
experience sucks it did when black site
came out and unfortunately it still does
on Sirocco now obviously I wouldn't
badmouth this map if I hadn't tried it
before so I spent the weekend playing it
really like just jump down and it's
still the core danger zone experience
that I got on black site which is you
have like less than 20 people not a
hundred not 50 not 75 less than 20 not
really a battle royale it's more like a
skirmish Royale or a gang fight royale
at that point you load onto a map that
is obviously much smaller than your
typical battle royale map now before you
even get on the map you have to pick
where you drop just like a typical
Battle Royale
except with a typical battle royale one
of the core mechanics of the drop is
that certain places have really good
loot and other places don't have good
loot at all but if you go to the place
with really good loot there gonna be a
lot of people there and you have to mix
it up with them and it can get kind of
crazy guess what danger zone takes the
decision-making away from you because
you land on predetermined hexagonal
squares throughout the map and you
cannot land on someone else's ex igano
square the loot is evenly distributed
throughout the map and by evenly
distributed I mean there's almost none
of it ah yes yes the empty rooms with
some money the classic csgo battle
royale all the weapons on these maps are
the lower level csgo weapons
ones that are less good the common theme
throughout them unfortunately is they
also have less range now with these
weapons and their limited range and the
extremely limited ammo that danger zone
provides for you you're put in this
sparsely populated map full of empty
rooms and like no people no no no USP
that's why you hit me from that range oh
my guys just spamming the Glock you'll
use your MP mp5 no ammo and he was so
far away this is cringe Oh any God Zeus
we got Zeus to lose that was a cringe
fight you see the thing about danger
zone is it just doesn't hold your
attention I'm really bad at csgo like
I'm really bad and I won black site all
the time and my first ever Sirocco game
I came second I got destroyed by a guy
with the USP across the map but hey what
can you do but if I'm getting bored of
it and winning that easily and dropping
it after a couple days what about people
who are actually good that's the reason
that people like shroud of skadoodle
didn't stream this very much after it
first came out it just doesn't have any
depth
now speaking of depth the latest map
Sirocco tries to address that in a
really really weak way which is by
giving you a choice of perks at the
beginning of the game there's just not
impactful or interesting or depth adding
at all
I picked the rocket boots because I
thought I was gonna be on some
fortnight's [ __ ] when I played this and
it barely affects your jump like it was
like imperceptible okay that was kind of
a rant on why I really don't like danger
zone and if you do that's completely
okay but I asked what the point was and
this is my point
this game is seven years old and
obviously counter-strike itself goes
back way farther than that it has built
an incredibly loyal fan base over the
years who loved the core aspect of the
game and now that Valve is starting to
patch the game more and make updates
I'll a vertigo the new economy change
things are looking up for its core
player base but this this is what Daddy
valve is spending its resources on now
let's do this
[Music]
all right it's a sign it's a couple yet
we're we're done we're done with this
waste of time this momentary sideshow of
a game I don't know anyone who wants
this I'm sure that there is a casual fan
base out there who does enjoy danger
zone so much that an update was
something they wanted but even if you
liked the experience you have to admit
this doesn't actually make any [ __ ]
sense because it all comes down to one
question who is this for is it for
existing csgo players who play your game
because they love competitive csgo or
hey maybe they love casual or or
deathmatch or something like that or
maybe they love wingman
I don't think so if they want to play a
battle royale there's a little game
called fortnight out there there's pub G
there's apex legends is it for new
players is Valve trying to bring in
fresh blood with this battle royale mode
well know again if they want to play
battle royale they'll play for a night
pub G apex legends or the Cod battle
royale or the other 10 million battle
Royales there that have their entire dev
team dedicated to making a BR experience
they're not gonna play this half-assed
butt-ugly Frankensteined game mode it
doesn't matter how many jump boots they
put in this game it will never match the
frequency or the magnitude of the wacky
cartoonish fun updates that fortnight
has it will never be fortnight it will
never match the extreme itemization and
customisation that pub G has it will
never be pub key they can put player
ping systems in they can put respawns in
which they did for Sirocco but it will
never be apex legends it will always be
a cheap bargain bin ripoff of those
games
[Music]
so if danger zone is gonna be relegated
to a tier two or three Battle Royale and
no one is switching off the other battle
Royales to play it well what exactly
again is the point
now look valve isn't stupid they usually
do things by the numbers and if they're
putting some resources to this I have to
believe there is a player base out there
that is consistently cueing danger zone
it's hard to believe but what else can I
do
valve does things for a reason right but
what I don't understand is this is sort
of like unvalued what they do best and
go out and acquire a good battle royale
instead of trying to Frankenstein one
into their old game so when you take
this player base that has been loyal to
the game for years it has a laundry list
that is an arm length long of complaints
of bug fixes of things they want quality
of life improvements and you give them
this it does feel like a tiny bit of a
slap in the face thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]